Trump today is January 20th 2017 is
inauguration data globally faces to
celebrate our new president we are
trying his food from trip grill from
Trump Tower in New York City which is
apparently now also Washington DC there
was an amazing Vanity Fair article that
declares Trump grill to perhaps be the
worst restaurant in America I know what
people say about Trump have an open mind
give his food a chance I think it will
tower over the rest get out of here is
the world we live in now Donald Trump
tweeted on Cinco de Mayo last year that
he loves Hispanics by eating his own
restaurants take on Mexican food build a
bowl I used to love taco bows in middle
school it looks like it's gonna be
pretty good white people love taco bowls
it's a deep-fried salad it's genius it's
[ __ ] genius
[Music]
I would dare to say it's not very good
this is his restaurant this is all he
eats all the time no wonder he's so
bitter and unhappy taco balls were
invented in America it's like saying you
love Chinese people and you eat fortune
cookies and now this is what happens to
the lettuce you can drain and it absorbs
all the liquid you put it on the bottom
that's why he's tweeting in the bathroom
at 3:00 a.m. when Trump sends his
Mexican food he's not sending its best
let's tear this wall down boring fake
Mexican sad
[Music]
classic everyone likes burger it's
really hard to mess up a good burger
right a Thousand Island dressing it's
probably how many Trump owns signature
color of Donald Trump we hired a
billionaire because he's in touch with
the working-class say what you want
about Trump but this burger is terrible
it's so overcooked oh my god it's the
driest meat my meat is the driest meat
if you can't make a decent burger how
are you gonna be president in United
States of America we make a lot of
burgers is too much bread is this a
cross-section of America this is not the
worst burger I've ever had but I have
eaten burgers off the floor this is all
I get as a tomato and I got like one
pickle I could get a better burger at
McDonald's imagine paying for something
that you think is gonna be good
you think it's reliable it's simple its
classic it gets you I get burgers and
then you get into the burger and you're
like oh there's no substance to this
these fries are terrible everything so
bad as burger is as dry as Mike Pence
which means it must hate the gays it's
overcooked it's bland it's boring sad
[Music]
from 2010 a simpler time I like rose' I
also like any alcohol monticello that's
ironic Jefferson will be furious
look God very bubbly things got out of
control and nobody stopped me you know
it's ostentatious but really kind of
lacking you know some rising up and
raise me up Tiffany you know I gotta go
bad for Tiffany it's got this weird
orange tinge to it or some out for
Hilary guys I'm in a really weird mood
right now
tiffany is Jan Brady and Ivanka is
Marcia Brady
so you've okay okay Blanca let's be
honest we're gonna need to drink a lot
the next four months years no months
what am i doing what I'm just eating
food for an Internet video people are
repairing a roof out there and I just
feel like a real [ __ ] right now so
this is evanka salad there's a tendency
for rich people in restaurants to name
their salads after their daughters why
is that funny it's right there let's
dive in crab cake on a Greek salad okay
this is the class and elegance that I
was expecting I'm surprised I mean I
feel like Greek would even be too ethnic
for the drums you know bad try the crab
cake looks string and fake-ass crab is
say it's really fishy it's too easy
what other jokes am I supposed to make
right Kelsey it's right there
wait is tossing the salad the anus or
the vagina oh it's the but well I've
tossed the water so then what am i doing
with my life why isn't Tiffany gonna
sell if my daughter's toss salad the
best her crabs overrated not good
problem sad sad I'll be honest steak is
usually one of my favorite meals
this has to be trumps and meat lining
trauma tenderloin that's a dick joke
there's not a great sear on the outside
where's the flavor I think it actually
is a legit quality piece of meat no
seasoning whatsoever why Strunk do all
this stuff he's not qualified for any of
it and I'm not lying guys this is all
underwhelming this better be good
oh my god the other guys enjoying these
potatoes I don't know I don't know very
good potatoes Oh
second buy the potato something is off
maybe I don't like these potatoes well
that was very sure that I like the
potato I'm gonna choose that I'm not
wrong you know I like the potatoes I do
you you're wrong I really thought I
liked the potatoes oh man he's the
president now my family came in at Ellis
Island early 20th century that's a long
time ago but when they came they were
like the [ __ ] and the bad guys I'm
like you know 100 years before that
those people were the [ __ ] and like
everyone that comes in originally
originally are viewed as like you know
bad because some people don't like
change but when you think about all of
America is immigrants except for the day
doing totally [ __ ] over but no one
ever wants to talk about and I you know
I'm really really I don't even know how
to talk about it now because I have know
very few Native Americans I'm just so
[ __ ] sick of it
that was really bad Donny boy you're bad
making fruit I say stick to your day job
but I don't want you to I did not come
in here wanting the food to be bad
having shitty food is inexcusable
[ __ ] you yo there ain't gonna be no
peaceful transition of power and my
bowels tonight look no matter who you
voted for we all want the same thing we
want better food and if you give people
bad food then you shouldn't be running
the restaurant
Trump has proven over the last few
decades of his career that he is really
good as a businessman he's great at
making deals he's great Edie the facade
and getting people to buy into the Trump
brand I mean Trump grill is an expensive
restaurant and one of the most expensive
parts of Manhattan which is one of the
most expensive cities in the world and
people eat there and guess what it's
[ __ ] there's no substance to it and my
only hope is that he puts a little more
care and thoughts into his current job
than he did this one
[Music]
oh they [ __ ] left here I am trying to
give them champagne this is just great
my white guilt is not suffice you know
it's still I'm just sitting out here
drinking fake rose' like an idiot